a picture of Afghanistan 100 years after
independence from Britain the
anglo-afghan treaty was signed this
month in 1919 by King Amanullah hon
graphic artists converted his image into
stickers for Kabul motorists other
canvases are blast walls falsified
concrete slabs placed information down
most city streets they meant to block
explosions from suicide bombings they
also offer a visual commentary on
carville society today whether it be
celebrations or more political
statements about corruption or the
killing of civilians Afghanistan's art
scene has flourished since the fall of
the Taliban in 2001 with literacy rates
among adults at only around 30% it's a
language all laugh Ganz understand
you're painting tulips today and every
single - that is for one of the victims
of wars Omar Sharif he and his team have
painted 10,000 so far their goal is
34,000 to represent the number of
civilians killed since 2002 Sharif he
founded the award-winning art Lords a
group of social activists turned
graffiti artists he is celebrating
Independence but not necessarily
Afghanistan's as a nation I think I have
my independence I have this art this
gives me the voice and this gives voice
to millions of our ones Zara Karimi has
a more traditional canvass film she's
making a short historical movie for the
anniversary this short film is just
short leave to the history of
Afghanistan through the path that we
passed to come to today and
and just give them like kind of clue
that what what we did wrong and what we
did right creamy is the first female
director of the Afghan Film Institute
and has been vocal and advancing women's
rights in Afghanistan we exist as a
country as a nation
so from some point of view we are
independent and what we we fight to be
more independent there's been a
turbulent century for Afghans with
independence defined as vastly as the
canvasses it is recorded on Charlotte
palace al Jazeera Kabul